انتصف الشتاء في حرب يراوح فيها الحسم
لترحل الخطط الى الفصل الانسب ربما الربيع
روسيا تنويش ان هجوم واسع خلال السته اشهر
لكن الرئيس الاوكرانيه يتوقع ما هو اسوا
تفوتا لن ينتظر طويلا والهجوم قد يحدث
خلال اسابيع توقعا مبنيا على تحركات الجيش
الروسي بيلاروسيا لكنه موسكو ايضا مهيئه
لحرب طويله والدلائل كثيره اولها كتيم
قدما المحاربين في الجيش من افغانستان عدو
دليلا اعتمده اعتمدته وزاره الدفاع ووزع
على المجندين الجدد من هم الاوكرانيون
اولو سؤالا في الكتيب والاجابه عليها كانت
الاوكرانيون رؤوس حولتهم الدعايه الغربيه
الى اعداء همجيين
استسلامه هما في الحرب يوتيوب يتيح
استعادتهم اخوه كما كانوا في السابق لكن
هذا الاستسلام ليس متاحا للجنود الروس فهو
بدايه لجاحي بالتعذيب من قبل الجيش
الاوكرانيه الذي حذر الكتيب من قوته عده
الغرب للحرب منذ عقود هذا بالنسبه للجنود
فماذا عن المدنيين تعاونهم مع الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه يحولهم في اعين الروس لونه
وبالتالي هم اهداف المشروعه الدليل الثاني
في الدفاع الروسيه اقر قواعد صارمه جديده
سجوننا في الجبهه لمن يعصي الاوامر
استخدام الهواتف والسيارات المدنيه ايضا
وذكرنا الاسبوع الماضي كيف رصدت القوات
الاوكرانيه الروسيه او ترصدت بها من خلال
مكالمات هاتفيه ومقاطع للجنود الروس نشرت
على مواقع التواصل
الدليل الثالث التجنيد من اجل تجنب اخطاء
الماضي وهنا ليعيدوا يعب مجلس الدمى
قانونا ليسمح بمصادره ممتلكات من يفرنا
الى الخارج وقت التعبئه
قدم
يتحدث خبراء وعسكريون عن ان موسكو تعد
مفاجاه واسعه نطاق لكيف وتوقعات بهجوم
مرتقب قبيل حلول الربيع بعد ان قامت موسكو
بتدريب
300,000 جنديا احتياطي تم التعبئتهم مؤخرا
وخلقت الظروف لحرب بريه اما من الشرق او
من الشمال او من الجنوب واستبداله قائد
العمليات العسكريه هناك ثلاث جبهات تنتظر
اوكرانيا خلال الفتره المقبله وبهجوم من
سيكون الاقوى للقوات الروسيه في محاوله
لتطويق جميع قوات الدفاع الرئيسيه
لاوكرانيا وفقا لتقارير اعلاميه الاولى من
منطقه تايدونيس كولوجاز والثانيه عبر
الحدود البيلاروسيا من الشباب والثالثه من
الجنوب من البحر الاسود
روسيه تعدها موسكو كما ذكرت مراسلاتنا
والوقت ليس في صالح كيف تاخر هجومها
المضاضي يعني فقدان هازمه المبادره ومن
اجل ذلك جاءت الدبابات
31 دبابه بحسب سفير الاوكراني في باريس
لكن وقت دخولها المعارك فعليا هو المشكله
الدبابات البولنديه اول الوافدين وارسم
بدات تدريبات الاوكرانيين مسبقا اختارت من
يمتلكون خبره في تشغيل الدبابات السعوديه
وبذلك خلصت مده التدريب من سنه الى خمسه
اسابيع اصول الدبابات الى الجبهات تحدي
اخر ربما يحتاج اسبوعين اخرين كيف لن
تغامر باربع 10 دبابه في المعركه قبل وصول
بقيه المدرعه افلام تحتاجوا وقتا اطوال
ربما ثمانيه اشهر والمشكله في صيامتها
المعقده وتوفير وقود الطائره الذي تحتاجه
لتشغيلها مهما صعبه لكن ومع ذلك يحاول
لكريملين استغلالها هذا الوقت لفرضي زمام
المبادره قبل دخول جيش اوكرانيا جديد
وبرامج التدريب الغربيه خير دليل
ستجري بريطانيا تدريبات الموسعه للجيش
الاوكراني في العام الحالي تحوي 20 الف
جنديا اوكرانيا وقد انضمت عده دول غربيه
بالفعل الى هذه التدريبات المتخصصون
البريطانيون يساعدون الجيش الاوكراني
بالتدرب على قياده طائرات الهليكوبتر
بالاضافه الى التدريب على الدبابات
البريطانيه تشالنجر القوات الامريكيه بدات
هي الاخرى تدريبات الموسعه للجيش الاخراني
في المانيا سيخضع من خلالها حوالي 500
لتدريب شامل على استخدامه ومدفعيه جديده
بما في ذلك مركبات المشاه المدرعه اضافه
الى 100 جندي اوكرانيا دوره تدريبيه على
نظام الصواريخ في الولايات المتحده كما
اعلنت بولندا عن بدء تدريب القوات
الاخرانيه على دباباتها ودبابات الشركاء
بما في ذلك دبابه الالمانيه وذلك بعد
موافقه برلين على ارسالها لكيف